[музыка]
Ветер гасит свечу, но разжигает пламя.
Задумайтесь, почему хаос,
неопределённость, кризисы и неудачи
уничтожают одних, а других делают только
сильнее и богаче? Почему одни ломаются
под давлением, а другие расцветают
благодаря ударам судьбы? Парадокс.
[музыка]
Сегодня мы разберём, почему одни и те же
события действуют на разных людей
по-разному. Мы поговорим о том, как
сделать так, чтобы проблемы и неудачи
работали на вас, превращая каждую
сложность в точку роста. Я раскрою вам
идеи о том, как превращать стресс и
ошибки, а также хаос себе на
пользу. Это пятое видео из цикла моих
роликов о суперпозиции.
Суперпозиция - это стратегия по созданию
такой ситуации, при которой всё, что
происходит с вами, идёт вам на пользу.
Вам закономерно везёт, и вы извлекаете
из этого максимальный эффект. Это видео
будет полезно всем, кто устал бороться с
проблемами и неудачами, кто хочет
понять, как оседлать хаос и
неопределённость, и особенно тем, кто
амбициозен и стремится достичь
максимальных высот в бизнесе,
инвестициях и в жизни. Поняв тему, о
которой будет идти речь, вы поймёте, что
кризисы, ошибки и неудачи - это не
негативные события, это ваши друзья,
которые делают вас сильнее и богаче. Вы
даже захотите, чтобы у вас было как
можно больше ошибок и неудач. Вы
буквально полюбите их. Поэтому
посмотрите это видео до конца, и у вас
откроются глаза на многие вещи. Я
уверен, для многих это будет большим
облегчением. Ну а пока подписывайтесь на
мой канал, ставьте колокольчик, активно
комментируйте и делитесь этим видео с
людьми, которых вы считаете
амбициозными. Поверьте, они будут вам
очень
благодарны. Если же вы хотите получать
больше таких знаний, то подписывайтесь
на мой Telegram-канал, где я делюсь
своими
инсайтами. Для начала давайте разберём,
что такое кризис и что такое
возможность. Вы все наверняка знаете,
что кризис и возможности - это, по сути,
две стороны одной медали. В китайском
языке для этого даже существует один и
тот же иероглиф. Так вот, кризис - это
не совпадение вашей картины мира или
ваших ожиданий, той реальности, в
которой вы
оказались. Вот представьте, что вы,
например, думали, что на улице тепло и
вышли в майки. А на улице в это время
холодно. Ну, зима, предположим. Так вот,
для вас эта ситуация будет
кризисом. А если бы вы вышли одетым
тепло, то для вас та же самая
температура стала бы возможностью.
например, возможностью поиграть в снежки
или покататься на лыжах или наоборот. Вы
вышли летом в шубе. Таким образом, мы
видим, что кризис - это всегда не
совпадение вашего представления о
реальности тому, что происходит на самом
деле. И это относится к любым жизненным
ситуациям. Будь то биржевой кризис,
экономический кризис или кризис в
отношениях между людьми. А что такое
возможности? Возможности - это ваша
способность извлекать пользу из таких
событий. А вот извлекать пользу из таких
событий вы можете только, если у вас
будут первое правильное представление о
ситуации и второе, у вас будет
правильная подготовка к ней. С этим всё
понятно. Здесь всё правильно, но
возникает небольшая проблема. А как
сделать так, чтобы у меня всегда было
правильное представление о ситуации? Вот
тут-то и кроется основная проблема. К
сожалению, мы не можем предугадать или
предсказать то, как будут развиваться
события. Что произойдёт в следующий
момент? Любая среда, любые
обстоятельства имеют динамический
характер. Всё быстро бежит и всё
меняется. Поэтому уповать на то, что
наше представление о реальности или о
ситуации всегда будет правильным, будет
большой
ошибкой. Кажется, мы зашли в тупик. Но а
что, если сделать
так, не заниматься предсказаниями
кризисов и негативных событий, а просто
быть готовым к любой ситуации на все
случаи жизни? Как сделать так, чтобы
всё, что с нами происходит, всё шло нам
на пользу? Представьте себе Гидру из
древнегреческого мифа о Геракли.
Согласно легенде, Гидра была
многоголовой змеёй, обитающей в
Глернейском болоте. В этом мифе
описывается один из двенадцати подвигов
Геракла. Каждый раз, когда Геракла
отрубал ей одну голову, на её месте
вырастали две новые. Так вот, про гидру
можно сказать, что кризис только усилял
её. Она была
антихрупка. О том, что такое
антихрупкость, мы поговорим позже. Так
вот, прежде чем стремиться стать
крутыми, нам нужно сначала исключить
возможности катастрофы и провала. Нам
нужно научиться делать так, чтобы
кризисы и проблемы только усиляли и
укрепляли нас, чтобы мы были готовы к
любой ситуации. И только после этого мы
можем думать о больших достижениях.
Иначе ошибки, проблемы и провалы не
дадут нам поднять головы, постоянно
отбрасывая нас назад. Теперь давайте
поговорим о том, что такое
антихрупкость. Этот термин ввёл
Насимтали в своей книге "Антихрупкость".
В ней он объясняет разницу в различных
состояниях. Существует три состояния:
хрупкая, хрупкая ломается от потрясений.
Неуязвимое, неуязвимое просто
выдерживает все удары, но не меняется от
стресса и потрясений. Антихрупкая.
Антихрупкая от потрясений становится
только лучше. Антихрупкая система
улучшается под воздействием стресса,
хаоса и
неопределённости. В отличие от хрупких
систем, которые разрушаются, и
устойчивых, которые просто выживают,
антихрубкие системы растут и
адаптируются. Проще говоря, хрупкая
ломается от тряски хаоса, устойчивая
выживает, а антихрупкая становится
только лучше. Давайте разберём ключевые
принципы антихрупкости. Всё антифрупкое
любит неопределённость. Оно любит хаос,
потрясения и кризисы. Оно хочет, чтобы
этого в мире было больше. Антихрупкие
люди и компании видят в кризисе и хаосе
возможности. Антихрупкость подразумевает
положительную асимметрию. Это когда
потенциальные выгоды намного превышают
фактические потери. Антихрупкая
стратегия устроена так, что небольшие
ошибки и удары почти не вредят. Зато
удача или прорыв дают огромный плюс. Это
мы разберём немного дальше.
Антихрупкость любит
диверсификацию. Чем больше у вас точек
опоры, тем меньше шансов критического
провала. В бизнесе это означает не
класть все яйца в одну корзину, не
зависеть от одного поставщика или
покупателя и не зависеть от одного
звёздного сотрудника. Ну и так далее. В
организме есть дублирующие органы или
пути компенсации. Чем более разнообразны
и распределены элементы, тем меньше
шанс, что один сбой погубит всё. Для
антихрупкости стрессеры являются
стимулами для
развития. Без нагрузки система
деградирует, а под стрессом она только
укрепляется. Стресс - это необходимые
условие для роста. Например, хорошая
команда, она как истребитель, она любит
скорость и нагрузки. Так вот, если
убрать вызовы, то лучшие сотрудники
начнут покидать команду. Представьте
график чашка из стекла. Чем сильнее
тряска, тем выше шанс её разбить. Или
стальной шар. Сколько бы вы его не
трясли, удары его не меняют. А пожар,
чем сильнее ветер, тем ярче пламя.
Антихрупкость - это искусство превращать
хаос в топливо для роста. Приведу вам
пример антихрупкости в нашей жизни.
Возьмём, например, наш иммунитет. После
каждой пережитой болезни он становится
только лучше. Посмотрите, например, на
то, что делают вакцины. Вакцины - это же
ослабленные бактерии болезни. Это, по
сути, контролируемый стресс, который
делает наш организм только сильнее.
Иммунная система тренируется на мелких
атаках. чтобы готовиться к большим.
Именно поэтому детям полезно играть в
грязи. Ну, в разумных пределах, конечно
же. Их организм таким образом знакомится
с микробами и учится на них правильно
реагировать. Возьмём спорт. Наши мышцы
всегда растут после нагрузки и
микротравм. Они становятся от этого
только сильнее. В то время как
неиспользование мышц ведёт к их
деградации, скелет тоже реагирует.
Физическая нагрузка повышает плотность
костей. Без нагрузки мышцы атрофируются,
а кости слабеют. То есть без стрессов
организм как раз и разваливается, а с
дозированным стрессом он становится
только выносливее. Перейдём к науке. Вы
знаете, что многие открытия сделаны
случайно через ошибки и неудачи.
Вспомним ту же вягру, которая была
незапланированным побочным открытием.
Как ни странно, именно ошибки учёных
двигают науку вперёд. В XIX веке один
химик пытался придумать синтетизический
каучик, а получил какой-то странный
порошок и поначалу счёл опыт
неудачным. Но эта неудача привела к
открытию пластика, первого пластика
бакелита. Вроде случайность, провал
эксперимента, а мир получил новый
материал. В науке полно таких
случайностей. от открытия пенициллина
флемингом, когда плесна случайно убила
бактерии в чашке до изобретения
микроволновки, когда шоколадка в кармане
инженера внезапно растаяла около
радиолокационной установки. Природа
повсюду показывает и учит нас: стресс
необходим для роста. Теперь давайте
посмотрим, как этот принцип проявляется
в экономике и бизнесе. Там тоже хватает
историй. В экономике рынки
непредсказуемы, а кризисы случаются
регулярно.
Одни компании банкротятся при малейшем
шторме, а другие любят ветер перемен и
взлетают благодаря ему. Знаете ли вы,
что почти половина компаний из списка
Fortune 500 была создана в период
рецессий или экономических кризисов?
Половина из топ- 500. То есть
получается, что смутное время - это
отличное время для старта. Примеры на
слуху. Microsoft появилось во время
спада семидесятых годов. Airbnb и Uber -
дети глобального кризиса
2008-9 годов. Эти компании не просто
выжили, они стали гигантами отрасли. А
согласно исследованиям университета
Стэнфорда и Вандербильда, стартапы,
запущенные в годы кризиса, имеют на 12%
больше шансов дожить до семилетия. И
растут они по выручке на 35% быстрее,
чем стартапы мирного времени. Парадокс?
Нет. Антихрупкость. кто проходит через
горнила кризиса, закаляется и обгоняет
конкурентов. Антикрупность можно
выстроить и в финансах. Насим Талип
советовал стратегию штанги. 90% капитала
вложить ультранадёжно и 10% в очень
рискованные ставки. Звучит странно, не
правда ли? Но смысл в том, чтобы
избегать умеренных рисков, где можно и
потерять ощутимо, и не выиграть многого.
Вместо этого быть одновременно
суперконсервативным и суперагрессивным.
Эта стратегия даёт положительную
осимметрию: ограниченный минус и
неограниченный плюс. По сути, вы в любой
ситуации выходите или не сильно
проигравшим, или очень
выигравшим. Примеры антихрупких подходов
в бизнесе на каждом шагу. Amazon, Джефа
Безнеса - классический образец. Безс
поощряет эксперименты и готов терпеть
неудачи, потому что знает, без них не
будет прорывов. Amazon запустил уйму
проектов, и многие из них провалились.
Но из некоторых родились сверхуспешные
направления Amazon Web Services, Amazon
Prime и так далее. Безс признаётся: "Я
потратил миллиарды на провалы". Девять
из десяти экспериментов терпят фиаску,
но один из десяти выстреливает, так, что
перекрывает все остальные. Другой
пример. SpaceX и Tтеesla. Маск открыто
заявляет: "Неудачи у нас допустимы. Если
ничего не проваливается, значит вы
недостаточно инновационны".
Антихрупкость проявляется не только в
бизнесе. Возьмём историю городов.
Великий пожар Лондона 1666 года
уничтожил 2/3 города. Огромная трагедия.
Зато после этого Лондон отстроился уже с
кирпичными домами вместо тесных
деревянных с широкими улицами, то есть
стал менее уязвим к пожарам и эпидемиям.
Город стал сильнее и безопаснее
благодаря этой катастрофе. Возникает
вопрос, как нам самим применять эти идеи
в нашей жизни?
Дам вам лишь несколько идей, хотя здесь
очень много эффективных инструментов.
Для того, чтобы стать более антихрупким
в жизни или бизнесе, вам прежде всего
нужно изменить своё отношение к ошибкам,
неудачам и кризисам. Полюбите их,
подходите к ним как к вашим помощникам и
необходимым условиям вашего роста. Ведь
избегая их, вы лишаете себя
возможностей. Во-вторых, определите,
где, в каких направлениях у вас могут
быть провалы, которые могут сильно
отбросить вас назад, привести к
катастрофе или к необратимым событиям.
Если сказать по-простому, вам нужно
понять, где вы хрубки. Третье. После
того, как вы определили то, где вы
хрупки, вам нужно оценить максимальный
ущерб, который вы можете получить или
сделать так, чтобы в случае
неблагоприятных событий ущерб был
минимальным.
Суть любого успеха заключается в том,
чтобы как можно дольше оставаться в
игре. Поэтому подумайте, что и где вас
может выбросить из игры. Четвёртое.
Никогда не полагайтесь на один сценарий
развития событий. Всегда допускайте
вероятность непредсказуемых событий, так
и вероятность своих ошибок. У вас всегда
должны быть как минимум три плана:
оптимистичный, реалистичный и
пессимистичный.
Пятое. Проверьте то, насколько вы
зависимы от кого-то или чего-то.
Подумайте о
диверсификации. И шестое. За какое бы
дело вы ни взялись, всегда стремитесь к
тому, чтобы ваши риски и расходы были
заранее известны и
зафиксированы, а прибыли или польза не
ограничены. Всегда ищите положительную
ассимметрию. Антихрупкость можно
развивать не только бизнесменам. Это
можно делать и людям, работающим в
найме. Например, вы можете развивать
разные навыки и направления
параллельно. Так вы менее уязвимы. Если
одна отрасль схлопнется, вы уже
потихоньку наработали навык в другой.
Это противоположность подходу вложить
всё в одно дело и молиться. Как
говорится в одной арабской пословице:
"На Аллаха надейся, а верблюда
привязывай".
Антихрупкость - это не просто модное
словцо, а новый взгляд на мир. Вместо
того, чтобы бояться хаоса, мы учимся
любить его и извлекать выгоду. Жизнь
постоянно бросает нам вызовы, и это
неизбежно. Вы можете прятаться в укрытии
и надеяться, что буря пройдёт мимо, а
можете, как мы сегодня узнали, просто
расправить паруса и использовать эту
бурю себе во благо. Ну или на крайняк
поставить ветряк и превратить силу ветра
в электроэнергию, будь то в бизнесе, в
творчестве, в личном развитии. Принцип
один: каждая ошибка - это урок. Каждая
проблема - это трамплин. Посмотрите, что
нам говорят мыслители древности и
современные миллиардеры. Фридрих Нисше.
Что нас не убивает, делает нас
сильнее. Синека. Трудности укрепляет ум,
так же, как труд укрепляет тело. Джефф
Безес. Большой успех - это серия неудач,
пережитых без потерей
энтузиазма. Илон Маск: Если не
ошибаешься, значит мало новаторства. Все
они об одном. Используй удары судьбы как
топливо. Я уже давно вдохновлён идеями
антихрупкости. Когда я размышлял о
концепции суперпозиции, я, конечно же,
не мог обойти антихрупкость стороной.
Антихрупкость - это один из трёх столпов
суперпозиций. Для того, чтобы добиться
суперпозиции в жизни, бизнесе и
инвестициях, вам сначала нужно обрести
антихрупкость, чтобы всё, что бы с вами
не происходило, работало вам на пользу.
Потом вам надо добиться закономерного
ввезения, чтобы удача сопутствовала вам.
Ну и, наконец, вам нужно научиться
инструментам, которые помогут вам
извлекать максимум из этих событий и
удач. Этому как раз я и обучаю на своей
преминой программе Акмы, что в переводе
с древнегреческого обозначает высшую
точку рассвета человеческого потенциала.
Акмы - это практический курс для
наиболее амбициозных бизнесменов,
жаждущих добиться максимальных
результатов в жизни, бизнесе и
инвестициях. В ней мы подробно разбираем
стратегию суперпозиции и как её внедрить
в свою жизнь. Если вам откликнулись идеи
из этого видео, программа Акмы станет
логичным продолжением. Вы не просто
поймёте, как работает антихрупкость, но
и встроите эти принципы в свою жизнь под
моим
наставничеством. Ссылку я оставил в
описании. Спасибо за просмотр. Если вам
было полезно и интересно, обязательно
ставьте лайк и подписывайтесь на мой
канал. У нас впереди ещё много выпусков
о том, как расти над собой и добиваться
выдающихся результатов. Поделитесь в
комментариях своими историями, что из
трудностей сделало вас сильнее. Мне
будет интересно почитать. Помните, мир
полон непредсказуемости, но теперь мы
знаем, что в этом наша сила. Будьте
антихрупкими и до встречи в следующем
видео.
[музыка]